[موسيقى]
تحذير جديد بشان تداعيات بريزات وهذه
المره من رئيس السلسله البيع بالتجزئه
العملاقه ماكس لوردسن فرجل الاعمال المؤيد
لحزب المحافظين ولخروج بريطانيا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي دعى الحكومه الى تخفيف
قيود سياسه الهجره التي تعوق النمو
الاقتصاديه وتسمح بجلب عمال من اوروبا
لملئ الوظائف الشاغره
في الحقول والعمل في المستودعات التي لن
تكون قابله للتشغيل من دونهم ولا نسمح لهم
بالدخول وعلينا اتباع نهج مختلف للهجره
وعلينا ان نتحكم في الهجره والسيطره عليها
بطريقه تفيد اقتصادنا
ومنذ الانفصال عن الكتله الاوروبيه زاد
بريكزيت من تفاقم نقص العماله في بريطانيا
واثر انخفاض الهجره من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي على عده قطاعات وخاصه في الضيافه
والخدمات والرعايه نظرا لنظام النقاط
الصارم للحصول على تاشيره عمل
نهايه حريه التنقل كانت احد عوامل انخفاض
العماله الحد ولكن نعلم انه ليس السبب
الوحيد فهناك مشاكل اخرى مثل عدم الجاذبيه
والاجور المتدنيه في بعض الصناعات مثل
الضيافه التي شهدت نموا منخفضا للغايه في
الاجور خلال السنوات الثلاث الماضيه واذا
ما نظرنا الى بلدان اخرى لم تشهد تغيرا
كبيرا في سياسه الهجره فان العديد منها
يعاني من نقص العماله ايضا
بعد مرور سنتين تقريبا على الانفصال
التامى عن الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يزال
الشارع البريطاني منقسما على نفسه بشان
بريزات خصوصا لناحيه مدى تحقق الفوائد
التي روجها مؤيده
ولكنه ليس سبب قله العماله بل الكسل
تداعياته
البريطاني في الربع الثالث ووسط التحذيرات
البنك المركزي من ركود طويل يتوقعوا ان
تستمر معاناته سوق العملي لملئ اكثر من
مليون ومئه الف وظيفه شاغره في ظل معدل
بطله هو الادنى منذ نصف قرن الا اذا ردخت
الحكومه لمطالب اقرار خطط لتسهيل هجره
اليد العامله
مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن